hallo wir kommen zu einem extrem
spannend work ssl verfahren zu kaufen da
nacht eingesperrt sein traum ein traum
nachts in der insel sumatra einfach
eingesperrt zusatznutzen dort jetzt
leben heute den werbespot für unsere
rausgehen
das ist wirklich kraft die creme kommt
zum kaufen wollte ist das was ihr bisher
was willst du alle schon wissen ja jetzt
weiß ich doch lieber jetzt aktuell
dürfen mal gar nichts verraten
das ist ein richtig also dieser tag geht
in die geschichte ein haben war erst
einmal eine halbe million abonnenten auf
youtube knapp worauf ich echt stolz bin
und dann noch die die creme bei kaufland
und wir drehen an seinen eigenen
werbespot ist heftig das wird ein team
von über zehn leuten seien wieder
mitwirkt
[Musik]
eine creme und kaufering und drittens
die leckerste ganze blätter
und ich bin dabei und er kann als mit
dabei diesmal endlich mal mit vor der
kamera sonst bist du hinter der kamera
der blick ist der platz
[Musik]
ist okay für
das untere fußball brauche ich auch erst
die schuhe aus dem auto man sieht das
anders
[Musik]
entweder habe ich es die bank von
spanien aus oder kauft dann versucht
sich eigentlich mehr stoff kaufen
[Musik]
sonst dieses
verbrechen
im korb
mitbringen
das geschafft
[Musik]
jannik diesem aritkel
ja
[Musik]
die screen da sofort für allzu wenig bei
kaufland
jetzt ganz genau wie ge verkehrt 446 ist
richtig platzkonzert
richtig ohg stimmen sich die leute
wissen sie gar das jetzt wegen
müdigkeit
[Musik]
das harte leben eines schauspielers
fehlt ihr noch die mütze auf
[Musik]
denn so anstrengend
wie lange nicht mehr
[Musik]
wie ist es so schauspieler zu sein sehr
hart und
jahren übrigens vor wie hinter der
kamera beste mitarbeiterin
[Musik]
den moment auf den wir hingearbeitet
haben
so krank
also ich weiß nicht was ich machen würde
es ist einfach gespart und gleichzeitig
auch emotional graf
hälftig
zu wurde das ist nicht
[Musik]
wir haben das im kaufland und gucken uns
die creme und da ist
sowie das gelingt kann ich jetzt meine
dienstag ist
jetzt gewinnspiel das seien leute das
riecht ein bisschen frage ist er gar ein
schreiben das
konstrukt
gutschein auf jeden fall nicht mehr
viele leute wohl hier fehlt es gewesen
sein müssen 23 12 12 x
also weshalb sie jetzt und es ist
donnerstag der hand kammer
[Musik]
wann immer nicht fahren darf
ja wie viele hattet ihr davon
okay okay alles per kurier danke dir ja
diese ausverkauft
ich bin traurig dass ich bin der trauer
ist anderes ich nicht bekommen ist meine
erste tag aber mir kommt jetzt auch
wirklich weil das zeigt das ist
einfach ein paar mal rauszukommen die
creme ausverkauft ist was macht ihr alle
hier noch ist niemand dabei aber was
macht ihr alle hier im hause gehen käme
sicher das machen ja dann noch
gefährlich also ich weiß aber nicht was
die leute machen machen wir aber die
kiwis kriegen ist hier seit 12 uhr
mittags ausverkauft wir haben jetzt hier
38 also was macht gerade noch nur den
land schließen oder nein kommt kaum aus
dem kunden dürfe deutschland ist war
[Musik]
meine queen ab dem 14 oktober in jeder
kaufland filiale
[Musik]